[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
or we talk about whatever we want
for today's author right here we have a
Drake here he's a rapper thank you for
that thank you for that introduction
music tells the best introduction I've
ever gotten in my life dude and I saw
the craziest [ __ ] Tweaker yes sir
last night oh you're old negative with
Little Tokyo really this guy comes out
it's called this [ __ ] last night
shirtless right and this dude's asking
us for stuff but he won't even let us
answer right so like we could hear
you're holding the jacket so this book
comes out heels what's up guys I think I
kind of money so trying to try to
respond back to him saying right if you
have any money I can happen to like that
beliving it's kind of like another level
that yeah he was in his own world yes
for food money the shirt on my the
sweater that I was ready to society cool
yeah maybe like that's right a cup
coffee or something - yeah you like the
span of like 10 seconds like maybe 15
seconds yes yeah we were just like he
must be new cuz you know there's like
bum regulars around there ya know but
the thing is he was kind of in shape
yeah yeah and then he had like this huge
scab in the middle of the glass shatters
I think yeah probably from like the
itches the cracking hmm
is he a tall white guy yeah yeah he is
actually but he's usually just cussing
or talking or asking for yeah cuz I was
like if he's shirtless yeah make sure
listen he has a big jacket or no jacket
[ __ ] jack he was completely shirtless
and he's wearing like legging does he
look like he could be handsome like his
face I couldn't tell ya I like he looks
and he looks young but old yes okay yeah
I was just I was like he's young but
he's like filthy like he's dirty yeah
yeah I know him dude one time the
description is like I know that guy
Oh cuz I lived there for two years right
you just get two amount of bums that are
always there the same ones and in they
all have their little quirks yeah this
guy I've never seen him hi but there's
been times where like oh I was there
with my family or we're walking down the
street and you'll walk by here oh and he
walks away no no he had a mission to
like ask for something but asked as many
things as possible as quick as possible
and then it's like he didn't even get an
answer just like right Wilfred well it's
cause like when he was talking about the
a mouse trying to raise my voice all I
could give him an answer I'll say sorry
yo okay give us a chance that man like
come on
but his speaking of homeless you guys
ever hear of the bum King before I've
heard that every like homeless colony
there's like the top dog yeah yeah so my
my friend's a fireman and he told me
about how like in Orange County
there was a bum king and like so he is
like the top dog of like the homeless
dingy yeah so if people want a Panhandle
in his territory they need to ask him
for permission
like can I
you may now kiss the hand you know kiss
the ring it's like with a dirty [ __ ]
purple glitter dildo is [ __ ] I think
like yeah he gets a cut of like whatever
it is you got paid taxes - yeah exactly
the bum tax right he's a bum yo real
[ __ ] though another guy wanted to take
him out and become the new bum King so
he got murdered the new bum it's a lawn
chair
oh my god there should be like different
clans no but what I heard about that
[ __ ] I was like that's crazy that's a
hot there's a hierarchy even within like
the homeless community I think is part
of human nature
right right right that's part of nature
yeah that's what the dumb thing about
that is the fact that if you are smart
enough to control a whole homeless
community get a really good job you're
clearly an intelligent human beings
manager material so on your resume what
if like in their standards right because
I think um some bum philosophy this is
why because one of my one of the one of
my old church members he actually took
in a bum and he learned about bum
culture and for him he was like there's
different like you were saying rules and
layers and cultures within bum world
like you have your guys theme park I
don't know if I want to go to that team
[ __ ] so there's like I guess there's
bums out there that are like sober they
don't do drugs but they just that's
their lifestyle like they're like
backpackers but that like hippies yes
they bow that's that's what they just
choose to do and a panhandle just to eat
and live and and that's it you know
there's an artist community in like I
think Salton Sea right past Palm Springs
it's the only technically a
city in the United States where it's a
lawless city oh you mean Slab City
I think it's called slap yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's a lawless city what does that
mean so there's no laws there it's on
BLM land there's an actual community
like you'll see a few documentaries on
this but there's just it's [ __ ]
lawless dude people are just dragging
out every single day
like whatever Rincon yeah but that they
tend to be very like liberal and kind
like they're not trying to rob each
other kill each other yeah it's just
more like they've intentionally outcast
like willingly outcasted themself from
society it's like Burning Man
yeah kind of like that except except 365
you know you're like live in that life
and then so their whole thing is we just
want to do our own thing and then not
have society like tell us or give us
pressures on how to be and what to be
I'm like that's kind of romantic you
know which is I mean that's like Anarchy
bomb like organized bomb right because
la bubblies it's like zombie cracklin
bomb it's a whole different world Carrie
did know but have you ever heard about
like the controversy of like when a lot
of the mental facilities were shutting
down in LA how LAPD officers were just
taking these people these patients who
had nowhere to go and just dropping them
off at Skid Row
all the people who ended up there just
have these mental issues so it's like
when you look at it from that
perspective because it's easy for us to
dismiss them and look at them like look
at that [ __ ] crackhead but then that
was like what in a 90 there's 80s or
something yeah yeah it was like well
most of those people are dead but
because we don't have a state us like
asylum like right like we used to right
right that's where all the crazy people
go yeah they don't have any family
yeah up schizophrenia you have any type
of like mental illness yeah they just
become homeless in that area that's all
the government-funded asylums just like
opened all the doors and they said
release crackin I don't know maybe
funding I know this is something yeah I
know I Donny there's a
oh yeah have you ever been to it I
haven't been to that one but I've been
to Linda Vista Hospital who did you go
with again so John you his one of his
artists was having a music video shoot
there and he knew that I was trying to
go there because I'm really super into
paranormal [ __ ] is that Pasadena and
Boyle Heights
yes we're never gonna kick it super into
that [ __ ] like I'm super the opposite
really super just shut down Hospital yes
it's been abandoned for a long time yeah
and then it's embroil height so they had
a lot of deaths there because it's in
like a gang neighborhood right yeah and
uh I tried to get into there like four
or five times unsuccessful say stay
raised I mean they hired security to
patrol the area during night - so many
people try to break in as private
property to get hurt - liability right
yeah and then one night like yeah our
friend John he's a music producer
hit me up he's like guess where I'm at I
like where he's like that Linda Vista
roll through I was like I'll [ __ ] be
there got a permit to shoot in there
yeah so they were shooting a music video
but it's a huge hospital and then it's
like there they don't have lights in
there so while they were shooting I
started kind of exploring by myself why
the [ __ ] would you do that just you know
provoke if there's anything there like
maybe they think I'm vulnerable what's
wrong with you do anything at all
earlier the ghost stuff like what the
rabbits think he's like boiling [ __ ]
Ayad Newt and trying to get every spirit
dude I could say yeah yeah we doing like
I would kind of like sit in these
they're the chairs that were there and
then I was thinking maybe it might
remind them of like a scenario that a
spirit there was in yeah and then my
kind of like they might do something
making noise or like doing action and
they seem you that you wanted it
they already knows like this
[ __ ] guy get boner boner boner
goes or go ghost boners boner boats did
the ghost of Jill has entered you and
gets a sneak in did you feel anything
while you're there why was there during
the day
oh it wasn't a night bill you just
called you a B okay I'm not trying to
act tough but I was there with friends
to like I wasn't there by myself what
the Ghostbusters in my book you're
pretty tough the fact that you just went
there even the daytime with friends both
that well yeah a so we ended up these
were in my rebel days so it's sexy
issues we ditched and then we went there
to go smoke back then they didn't have
security especially during the day then
yeah yeah and so yeah and then one of
the walls it looked like it was blood
splattered mmm on the wall and then
there was just all these papers
it was just Bobby Lee [ __ ] on did you
feel anything that so I there is a the
part of the hospital where I guess they
had they stored like the dead bodies and
stuff and then it's kind of in the
basement when I was down there there was
a section where it's like ice-cold you
know and it's [ __ ] weird because like
everywhere else in the room is room
temperature but this one section is just
ice cold so like you could be standing
and then put your arm out like this and
then you start getting cold yeah cuz
like so cold in there and the rest of
your body's warm but maybe it was under
AC vent the insulation is really bad but
then some of my other friends ended up
coming they definitely had experiences
yeah they had they felt people tapping
them on the shoulder and maybe you're
nice they were joining us I know I was
just too excited yeah and then the ghost
is like he's gonna get scared you might
get too excited and then other people
heard like whispers in their ear while
we're walking they're like what the [ __ ]
and I'm like what like do something he
wants been hella jealous huh yeah I was
like why am I not getting because I got
is coming up to you they're like this
now the trip you should note was like
because there were no lights we were
using our phones for the oh my god and
then everybody was at 75% or higher like
literally within 10 minutes like
everybody's battery drained down to like
10% 50% and then you know they say
spirits try to use like electronics to
communicate I don't know what it was but
everybody's battery batteries drain so I
think by using the flashlight your
battery drained no yeah and the only
thing I think I really felt was uh there
was an attic and then nobody was willing
to go up there so I said [ __ ] it i'ma go
oh my god as soon as I got your like why
people in a [ __ ] [ __ ] movie let's
investigate yeah exactly
I gotta investigate umm and I went up
there and it felt like my oxygen got cut
in half the moment I walked through the
door it was really hard to breathe so
like best way to describe it as soon as
you walk in it feels like somebody just
pushed on your chest like this and
you're like trying to breathe you're
like oh [ __ ] that's the ghost telling
you don't come here yeah yeah so I
couldn't I couldn't last more than like
a couple minutes in there and then I
just went back down and then they're
like eh so how was it
let's go check it out was nothing there
tell them to go let's go check it out
nah it's just I don't know it's like you
know cuz I've had a lot of paranormal I
guess
incidents that happened in my life oh
yeah at least like five times
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah see this is my thing
dude I guarantee you there's a lot of
paranormal stuff that's happened to me
where I've kind of noticed it but I do
this I go nope no no no did it ever
happen to any of you guys like no I just
say Jesus yeah I say in the name of
Jesus Christ protect me Christ are some
hands in [ __ ] I [ __ ] make a cross out
of anything ya know I had dope [ __ ]
happen though Oh
like what do you mean like with with I
mean I don't even know it's going
started filling up on her titties
by your titties like that explains the
whole getting elevate the carnival toy
did the clock what happened
the most recent stuff that was dope was
when my dad passed like that whole time
like I guess the whole like two or three
weeks afterwards um so he collected a
lot of quarters and then like there were
just random quarters that would pop up
like I shut I think it was wild i
bathtubs were at the corner like I don't
buy into this like I don't buy into how
many showed up that's not like that's
how much it helped him empty on is
haddock solo people like think about all
quarter collection must be like a jar no
we were going up in down through the
like three or three emergency money just
in case like if the house burns or
whatever like you can always repeat that
something ah so yeah so after you past
like like a few weeks after like you
like I'd be here and you'd look at this
table and there's nothing on here right
there's no quarters or whatever and then
like like maybe a few minutes later I
like would pick up my phone and there's
like a quarter then I'm like what stop
wasn't ask you something what where was
Bart uh I don't know what was in that
room just to let you know if I was this
[ __ ] it was happening to all of
our like all of the immediate family and
he wasn't there yeah uh so that was
really comforting [ __ ] like that so [ __ ]
like that happens to me where it's like
a positive and I've never had anything
like even went on the barbel retreat
you found quarters in the campsite yeah
I got an Airbnb it'd be like a quarter
like honor justice random places for him
and it would just be me and her seeing
it like you would the other people see
it was weird I was like dude I was just
standing here the whole [ __ ] time
there was nothing here you save the
quarters yeah and whatever happen when
you coughed but you just farted and
humor [ __ ] dad come on not again this is
your dad's one left pop this is if there
are if there are family ghosts I wish
that I hope that they could take like
they could stow away on an airplane or
something cuz that'd be nice if my
grandma could come back everything you
just told me you didn't send a single
grandma like this I saw that video what
do you want it'll be cool it's like when
you die right then you can understand
all languages you can observe the whole
entire world
you could you could teleport your spirit
to any place anytime watch any of your
family members or whatever they'll be
[ __ ] awesome astral plane yeah astral
plane is like when you reject yourself
I'm not trying to astral project nothing
you just gotta take DMT right me [ __ ]
ass me into dude my grandma don't know
how to find me she does I'm sure she it
does exist
dude that would be so [ __ ] funny if I
could like astral project my body out
and then there's like this other world
creature that sees an empty vessel and
they go in and their hell upset because
like we all see it his knees don't work
his hagel don't work just floating
talking switching back [ __ ] enjoy you
still crashing system I break my new
ankles that'd be crazy you guys used to
your old body so much you turn that new
body into your old body I know no switch
again did but you know that DMT stuff
like is so weird to me because I want to
believe that there is this other world
out there but everybody's experience
with DMT is different they all go to a
different place right so how come is
unless there's a case where 7000 like
whatever everybody goes to the same
similar place then maybe it might be
believable believable for me right but
everybody's experience is so vastly
different yeah your experience is also
determined by all the things that you
went through yeah and all the walls that
you built up through like your
insecurities that make more sense to me
then if everyone went to one place
because there oh that would know but
might what I'm saying is if everybody
went to one place that means that this
place exists right he said if
if everyone's the same place then there
is that alternate dimension but since
there isn't that alternate dimension
that everyone is just experiencing it
would be the way that the drug is me
because everyone when you get high you
experience similar symptoms like what if
it's just the actual drug that takes you
to the same place but because everyone
goes to a different place that to me
sounds more like it is believable it
like you're going to a different didn't
so you're you're like it's more like
Rick and Morty yeah you go to different
places each time see that's that's too
hard to prove though do you see them
saying because my thing is more provable
and then they don't help me believe it
everyone had the same experience every
time you smoke a [ __ ] Green Goblin
green reader it's like that [ __ ]
kawaii cafe it's like okay so it's a
it's a transgender Japanese dude that's
made nasty
his name is nasty you guys remember that
we went to the cafe
he was hello everybody my name is a mess
kept getting mad because we kept
interrupting his presentation so he was
getting a [ __ ] attitude - it's like a
presentation do the double doors opened
up and then he comes everybody my name
is a nasty and he has these [ __ ] big
ass movements and [ __ ] you would think
he's exaggerating but he's probably
doing it very underwhelming yeah it's
like a understated presentation it's
[ __ ] wild yeah and every time he says
a word yes two switches pose yeah
today we are going to have a cab in our
space sure is a quarter getting the
spaceship is a rabbit go on floor it's a
while
since the menu is so weird we have a
purple cab weird [ __ ] if everyone saw
nasty I think it'll be real
[Music]
[Music]